the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
ok let's start so today we're gonna do
some NP hardness reductions so let's
just do a quick recap of P and NP so so
P is
same decision problem so have an input X
and you have some algorithm a and spits
out an answer which is either 0 or 1 so
that's a position problem and if a
problem is in P this algorithm 8 runs in
polynomial time so what about NP so NP
is when the solution is verifiable in
polynomial time so let's say you have an
input X and some Oracle which is good
you can run in exponential time or as in
computation time gives you an answer so
you have you get X and you get an answer
which is either 0 or 1 and you also get
a certificate let's call you have a
certificate and given these three values
you can you can verify whether the
solution was correct or not in
polynomial time make sense so clearly if
you can compute the answer in polynomial
time you can also verify in polynomial
time
so P is a subset of NP and so that's it
okay so now np-hard problems our
problems that are at least as hard to
solve as any problem in NP and so now
we're driven goals and reductions so I
think they did something in class
Nintendo games or something ok so today
we're gonna do some less interesting
examples but let's see so so how do we
do reductions so if we know that we
haven't we have a problem a which is a
hard problem and we want to show that
problem B is hard
so you want to draw this implication so
let alone draw this implication so this
is equivalent to saying that if if B is
easy then this is the contrapositive so
if you can so assuming that B has a
polynomial time solution it has a
polynomial time solution and that
statement is it cool to say if a is
heart beat so if you know that a is a
heart bro and P heart problem we can say
that B is np-hard bro so first we show
so if you want to show that B is an
np-hard problem first we show that B is
an NP and then we saw that B is hard
okay so the way we do that so the way we
do this step is let's say oh you're so a
looks like this you have your blue
Bardem and it spits out an answer and 0
to 1 and B looks like this say you have
an input Y and spits out an answer and 0
to 1 and you want to find a function R
which takes your X and sends it to Y so
basically if you know how to solve B
very fast then you can take an input to
a you can so you take X you transform it
and then you apply B and the condition
is that they applied to X is the same as
B applied to our FX so basically what
you're doing is you're showing that a is
easy by showing that you can use so
let's say B is easy we can use B to
compute a so then a must be easy but
since we know that a is hard that
there's something wrong in our logic so
B must be hard
does that make sense
anyway so let's move on to let's move on
to an actual problem so the first
problem we're gonna reduce is the
Hamiltonian path so one so a well-known
NP so L Oh an np-hard problem is the
Hamiltonian cycle so here are eight is
so it's a Hamiltonian seconds what's
Hamiltonian cycle so help me recycle so
let's say you have a graph show this
graph
okay so Hamiltonian cycle is a cycle in
the graph which starts at some vertex
visits all the other vertices and comes
back to the starting vertex so in this
case we could do something like go here
I'm gonna take this vertex take this
vertex take this vertex and come back
here so that is the valid Hamiltonian
cycle so this graph is Hamiltonian cycle
so the decision problem is here that
given a graph does it have a Hamiltonian
cycle and that problem is np-hard
so you can't you can't solve a
polynomial time so now then the new
problem that will show is np-hard which
is B is Hamiltonian path so now I'll do
link path this is very similar problem
instead of cycle you just you require to
remove the requirement that you to come
back to the starting point you just
start anywhere and visit all the
vertices and stuff so for example if you
remove this edge this graph no longer
has Hamiltonian cycle but it has a
Hamiltonian path which is just this line
so so so this is a simple reduction
because the problems are very similar so
the first step is of course saying
showing that Hamiltonian path is in NP
so so that should be pretty clear
because so what is that certificate here
so if someone says ok I've solved a
Hamiltonian path and this is my
Hamiltonian path so the hell thorium and
he gives you a certificate which is the
actual path so you can always look at it
the certificate check the path and see
if it's valid path and then you can
verify the answer in polynomial time
that's the linear time verification so
so this is this is true so now would you
show is these hard
so we do that is we do a reduction the
reduction is given an input to the
original problem a so let's say an input
to a is in the form of a graph so and
now you transform this graph somehow to
G Dash and then you have to argue that
so this is the transformation are and
you have to argue that the solution the
answer that this will spit out is the
same as the answer that it was this
works that out
so let's look at the transformation
first and you have any idea so let's say
so you have a graph and it had an ear
that's a new region that is all the
Hamiltonian cycle problem so how do you
transform it in a way that lets you cast
into a Hamiltonian path formulation
not exact so you don't know so which
edge would you removes you don't know
the helmet you can't find the
Hamiltonian cycle okay important point
so there is no point doing this
reduction unless this reduction is
itself polynomial because otherwise this
like whole strategy of transforming and
then using be to find a doesn't work
because if if the reduction is
exponential time that doesn't help you
so see so if you so if you remove some
edges you will see that there is still a
Hamiltonian cycle but if you really
remove some edge so so it doesn't so you
can't tell like that so you don't know
which edge to remove so a better way to
do it what is this so let's say this is
the rest of your graph and you just look
at one vertex so look at one vertex V
and let's say this is a directed graph
it's an undirected graph you can just
like add one edge there and one edge
back for everything so now you add a
directed edge along this sorry you look
at the all the directed edges so let's
see if somebody is coming in and if
somebody's going out so this is just a
vertex and you just look at the rest of
the graph and look at all the edges
coming in and all that is going out so
this is an eight this is the original
problem and you transform this into you
split the vertex into two so V Dash and
V Double Dash let's say and in one of
them you keep all the incoming edges and
the other one contains all the outgoing
edges does that transformation make
sense intuitively so what do you have
here so here you had so let's say let's
say this graph had a Hamiltonian cycle
so this graph had some cycle which like
went up here did something something and
came back so it would go like this it
would do the cycle and come back so
there was some cycle and since the cycle
it contains V so now what you're doing
is you're splitting apart V and
disconnecting them so you'll still have
if you look at the original path it's
still there but it's it's been split up
into a path now it's no longer a cycle
so let's let's argue this more
rigorously
so what we want to say here is that
let's say there was a cycle here if
there was a cycle here then is it clear
that there is a path here because just
take the same just take the same edges
that you had before if you take the same
edges they will now form a spat instead
of a cycle so cycle implies path that
makes sense so the other way is a little
more tricky so let's say you let's say
you have a path let's say so let's say
you had a path so that meant that that
means that so let's draw this redraw
this it's more clear so you have this
new graph where you have two vertices V
Dash and B Double Dash this has a bunch
of incoming edges and there's a bunch of
outgoing edges so now let's say you have
a Hamiltonian path in this graph so what
does that mean so we're working the
Hamiltonian path start then it start
anywhere we're gonna start race because
V double Prime doesn't have any incoming
edges so it can't be in the middle of
the path so the it has to start here so
it starts it does something in there and
where can it end
you can only end similarly in V dash
because V dash doesn't have any outgoing
edges so it can't be the middle of the
path
it has to end in V dash so now if you
have a path like that and you go back to
this for this this graph so V and V dash
V dash in V Double Dash and now for the
same vertex and that just that path just
becomes a cycle now it's a path implies
cycle so that I'm so now now what we
have as previously already had right so
now we know that a of X or rather a of G
here is equal to VF g dash so g dash was
transformation also notice that the
transformation was just splitting apart
of vertex total like take depending on
your representation of your graph it
will take something like a constant time
or linear time or something polynomial
essentially so you get a polynomial
reduction you after a reduction you show
that the answer to the reduced
is the same as the answer to the
original problem and that means that
this is this is also an np-hard problem
by the argument getting questions does
that make sense yes no it's just one
just pick anywhere Dex doesn't matter
because you have a cycle so if you take
up to take any vertex s planet apart you
get a path ok let's move on to the next
one so the next problem is so
so given a graph is there a cake click
this is do people know what a click is
okay so what I saw click is this so
click is a set of vertices so let's say
C subset of V for the set of vertices
such that C is a complete graph so what
is ok let's just draw a diagram that's
really easier so
okay so in this example so you have this
graph drawn so look at look at this set
of vertices every pair of them is
connected to each other what that means
is that if you just look at just look at
the graph with these vertices it's a
complete graph but that's what's called
a clique and in this case this is a for
clique so your former disease is it for
claim so so the decision problem is
given the graph does there exist a K
clique so this is again known to be an
NP hard problem so now we will use this
to show that this problem is np-hard so
this problem is independent set so again
so given a graph what is an independent
set anyone want to explain okay so what
an independent set is this so let's say
you have a graph which looks like
so kind of complementary to the
definition of a clique and independent
set is a set of vertices such that no
pair of them has an edge between them so
in this case if you took this vertex
each of this vertex you took this vertex
this vertex and this vertex so you can
see none of these vertices have an edge
between them so that is an independent
set so in this case you're taking a set
of vertices which have we which is a
complete graph so all of the edges
between them and this case you're taking
vertices which are completely
disconnected so now we're gonna try to
find a reduction from this problem to
this problem so first of all independent
set is in NP is that clear how would you
show that so how would you create a
certificate which would tell you that
how would someone create a certificate
which would convince you in polynomial
sign that this is an NP this that this
is correct so just just so the
certificate would be just give you the
independent set and you can check if
something is independent set so let's
say so given I let's call the
independent set I so given a set of
vertices you can verify that it's an
independent set in polynomial time so
just like look at all pairs and check if
there's an edge just on mine square and
cube whatever it's polynomial that's
important okay so now let's look at a
transformation so so again as before you
have a which is which is given by a
graph and you want to transform it to
something so the important to note here
is that in in the clique you have
so if you have a click see all pairs of
vertices connected and in I know pair of
vertices are connected so what what
should be a logical transformation that
would map a clique to an independent set
what do you think you should do to the
graph so the clique becomes an ya
precisely yep is that great so what all
you have to do is if you want to turn a
clique into into independent set you
just remove just invert the you just
what is it complement the adjacency
matrix so every edge that does not exist
now exists and every eyes that did exist
is gone so you created a graph G - wait
the same numbering vertices except the
edges are now complemented so the e bar
just means the edges that were not so
let's let's draw an example so say you
had
okay and and what does this become so
let's draw the vertices first okay let's
go on my own
so let's take this vertex so let's take
this vertex and what I just does it have
so it goes here it goes here it doesn't
go here so we draw an edge here it
doesn't go there we draw another edge
there and it doesn't go there so we draw
another edge there
no this vertex it's connected to all of
these except this one so that means that
there's an edge there let's take this
vertex it's connected to everything oh
it's an active everything okay let's
take this one it's connected to these
two nothing else so we need to connect
it to this guy and I think that's it
yeah similarly so proceeding this is
connected to everything except that so I
guess this goes there and that's it or
is there more okay so that is the
complementary graph I think so
you can probably verify that so now
let's look at the clique in this graph
so this is the clique this is the
largest quick rather this is a clique
you can have other cliques like for
example this these three things are also
click so now look at what this is
mapping Jo so this is mapping to this
vertex this vertex this vertex and this
vertex and you can see like that's an
independent set so does that translation
make sense so now the proof should be
intuitively clear so let's just go
through it like miley rigorously so
let's say you have a clique here so you
know click here for every pair of
vertices in the clique there is an edge
between them and so that maps to so
let's say clique C maps to
she just Maps try so for all UV element
to see you have UV element of e so for F
so if since it's a quick for every pair
of vertices that that edge is in the
original graph which means that UV is
not an element if e for all u comma V
element of I so for every element for
every UV element if I we have this which
means that dimensions so that means that
this is so then event that that's the
independent set criterion so now we are
ready so you reduce quick to independent
set and that means that independent set
is now might be hard okay how are you
doing on time okay let's so now let's do
a more complicated example any questions
on these to make sense okay so let's try
this
hmm
[Music]
so there's the next problem so as before
our a is a click and well so it says
there's a click rather looks like this
in this way click size greater than
equal to K so that's the decision
problem is there a clique of size
greater than equal to K and B is it's
been called max 2sat so what that means
is that so it is little somewhat like
normal to set except so basically you
have some clauses and you have some
literals so each of these literals can
take values 1 or 0 and each of these
clauses is something like X I or XJ and
actually they're coming knots in front
of this so let's go let's say X I not XJ
or any other things so it's X I not XJ
are not xj xj x I not XJ or X I XJ and
so on and so forth so the just normal to
that so now the decision problem is to
does there exist an assignment
such that greater than equal to k
clauses that is this problem so is there
an assignment to literals
such that at least K of these clauses
are satisfied and so now we're gonna
show that it is good so again is it an
NP so what is the certificate so how
would you how would someone convince you
that this problem is like there is a
solution to this problem right yeah so I
give you an assignment of values to
literals and then you can go through all
the clauses and check them so if they
give you the x1 equal to 1 x2 equal to x
equals 0 x3 equal to 1 and so on and so
forth you can then go through and check
all the closets and see if greater than
k could never satisfied so this is an NP
so now let's try the reduction so this
other reduction goes so let's see so I
actually have decline are greater than
equal to K quickly so that means have a
graph with a set of vertices and a set
of edges and let's say so let's say you
have a clique be - a subset of V and mod
of V dashes so now you want to somehow
construct literals it's gonna construct
clauses which will reflect this behavior
so first of all this may not be clear
right now but let's say we take some
literals like this so let's say we take
X I for all for all I element of V so
for every vertex in the graph we take a
literal so we have if the number of
vertices then we have n literals whereas
corresponding to each vertex also we
take dummy literal let's call it Z
so now how do you read our classes so
the basic the general idea here is that
if if a vertex is in the click you will
assign it 1 if it's not in the click we
will assign it 0 so if we want so
basically we want so everything outside
outside of everything outside of the
flake is 0 so this class not X I or not
XJ so 1 of this what is the value of
this class normally so let's say X I and
XJ are both are both outside the clique
so I enjoyable that side a clique that
means that this is both of them are 0
and so this is true what if one of them
is inside the clique and the other one
is outside it's still true because one
of these knots is 1 and therefore it's
still true let's say both I and J are
inside the clique so you know so in that
case you have X naught of X I is 0 and
out of X change also 0 so this is but
that's the only case in the business of
bolts so the way we take care of that so
we wanted we were trying to maximize the
number of true clauses in some sense
it's like a hand maybe explanation of
why we're using this class so we do
instead of taking all the xixj pairs is
we just take X I XJ such that I comma J
is not an element to see what does that
mean so now if you had the graph which
looked like this now 1 2 3 4 so you
would take not x1 and not export you
take not x1 and not extra but you would
not take not x2 and not x3 so what is
back to that means that if you follow
the assignment according to the quick
rules for therefore every I so if ing
are both in the click this this class
will not be included does that make
sense
what's that of causes we're taking ok so
let's continue and it'll probably be a
little more clear so the other sort of
class we're going to take is X I or Z
and the other one is X I or not see the
reason we're taking these is that if you
wanted to max max 2sat
on this on this alone you could just set
everything to 0 and that would give you
a maximum so to sort of like not do that
sort of minimize the number of things
that you set to 0 you're doing this so
this is just the hand wavy argument why
you're doing this so let's actually try
to do some analysis on this so let's say
you do those transformations to do the
clauses make sense there's a first class
makes sense if you have so you have not
xixj for every IJ which is not in the
graph so how do this work so let's say
you have let's call it B dash such that
size of V dash is greater than equal to
K actually let's just let's just make
sizes
V dash equal to K so if you have a
clique of size greater than equal to K
of course you have a clique of size
equal to K can just throw away some of
the vertices so you take you take a V
dash such that this size is equal to K
and you set X I is equal to 1 so as you
said X ie equal to 1 if I this element
of V dash 0 if I is not an element of V
dash make sense so you'd set everything
in your clique to be 1 and everything
outside to be 0 and let let Z equal to 1
so you're starting with the assumption
that so you're showing one direction so
we're showing that given that there is a
clique of size greater than equal to
scale and now we're going to construct a
max 2sat instance which has the
satisfied number of classes greater than
equal to K and then we'll show the other
direction so so now let's look at how
many clauses we have to be satisfied so
so the first first type of clause was
not of X I or not of XJ so how many of
these calls are being satisfied so first
case I and J are both outside B - is the
class satisfied in that case yes because
you're by definition if they're outside
v - they're both zero so the knots are
both one so they're one so if the ingr
outside v - you're good
so what about the case when one of them
is inside B - is the class satisfied so
it yeah
because one of them is one of one of
them is zero which makes the not one and
the whole thing is it's an or so it's
let's say both of them are inside v -
let's say both I enjoy inside v - then
this class just doesn't exist because of
the condition that IJ had not elements
of e because if it's inside the clique
then that edge obviously exists and
therefore this class is not not in the
set of classes we are using so
essentially every clause of this form
will be satisfied and how many closets
of this form are there the number of
files of this form is just e bar where
is the complimentary edge set of that
graph that's e bar okay does that make
sense
so all right next Clause is X I or Z so
since we have recently took Z to be one
this bar is always satisfied so this
just gives us mod of V because so every
F so this is for every I so I should
mention that so for every I so the home
a number of excise RV that's it
so the third type of cause is X I or not
of Z so naught of Z since Z is 1 naught
of Z zero so the only cases where this
clause is true is where is when X is 1
and X I is 1 only inside v - so the
number of pilots Attis fide here is mod
of B - and mod of V - is just game
you see this the does that mean so all
three colors make sense so can you see
why the first one is it's the size of V
bar because all the clauses are
satisfied the second one also all the
clauses are satisfied because Z is 1 so
that's every every clause is just the
number of vertices and the last one it's
only satisfied for the cases where X I
is 1 and X I is 1 only inside a clique
so that gives you the K things in the
clique so now we can finish formulating
our transformation so a transformation
was you set so yes so these are these
are our classes and now we have set the
key right so the max 2sat was with the
condition of K so here you set it to be
modify bar plus come out of the plus key
so basically so our max 2sat problem so
the reduction to the max was that
problem so we specified the clauses we
specified the literals literals were xi4
all-ivy
and the dummy z we certified the clauses
and we specified the threshold we are
trying to achieve so that could so those
three things completely specify the max
2sat problem so ok proceeding so observe
that this is so we just showed one
direction we showed that if there is a
clique of size greater than equal to k
we reduce this to a clique of size
exactly K then we did then we did this
assignment and we showed that the total
number of clauses being satisfied is mod
of V Bar plus mod of V Plus K and that
is that is the first direction so now
we've shown that so if you have a
solution to click we have a solution to
case a max K set so now we do the other
direction so let's say we have a
solution to Max key set
that's not really okay let's do this
so let's see
okay so this part of this is more tricky
so we start with max case add has a
number of satisfied clauses which is
greater than equal to mod of V bar plus
V plus key so we know that so max when
we know that max that accepts do you
even know that so we define you define a
V dash then this V dash is in the graph
for clique as the set of vertices I such
that X of I equal to 1 so if our max a
sign has that many things then there is
some assignment to X I which satisfies
that and we take that assignment and for
every value that is 1 we put that in a
it's not it's not a clique yet but it's
it's well it's a clique under
construction so we can make this clique
under construction and we assign it
values of the all the vertices which are
currently enabled y1 but you don't know
does it click right it could not be a
quick it could be something like let's
say this is the current V - so we -
could be something like you have all
these vertices and they sound let's say
some of them are connected but then you
have this dangling okay so this is not
connected this is not connected so it's
not a clique so let's say let's say this
is a vertex I and its vertex J and this
whole thing is V - and let's say somehow
you have this anomaly you have that this
guy is not connected to all the vertices
so let's take one such pair and let's
just say we remove we remove X I so you
stick we just take the X I and removed
from V - and what that equates to in the
max K set is setting X I to 0 so we take
the original satisfying assignment and
change the value of x I so let's see
what that does so we take and set
my next night was originally one so
let's actually write it up
so X I rather I comma J is not an
element defeat but so these IJ were in
the supposed to be quick but the I comma
J is not in the edge set so it's not
actually a clique so the way we resolve
that is just like we do if we say okay
let's let's just forget about this
vertex let's say just not in the clique
so we said on excited 0 and what does
that do let's look at how that effects
the number of sat clauses so the first
one is X or Z so now here we have not
said the set Z to be 1 this is this has
been like this is something in thing but
we can just we can if Z is equal to 0 we
can just replace Z by not of Z so like
the closets are symmetrical with respect
to Z right so it's I X I or Z or X I
naught C so it doesn't matter which one
we said to be 1 or 0 like one of those
one one of them is zero so let's just
say that Z is 1 without loss of
generality so what that does is so
initially this clause was one because YZ
1 and now it goes to 1 and nothing
changes okay that's good sounds good
what about the next one so now we have X
I or not of Z so however it's not a Z 0
and X I just went from being one to
being 0 so what that what happens here
is that the nature need the clause value
was 1 and now it goes to 0 so we let's
not good because we just like we could
have now we are no longer satisfying max
case at possibly because we had some
number of satisfying clauses which was
above our threshold but now I'm
surprised like oh now we lose a clause
and we could be going below the
threshold but then we look at the third
clause now what that does is
so let's see let's say we look at this
specific class the one which said that X
I and XJ note that this clause exists
because X I XJ is not an a genie and
therefore by that condition this clause
is exists in the set of clauses so what
was the value of this class initially
before in the initial assignment what
was the value of this clause note that X
I and J are both in V - so was the value
of that this clause in the original
assignment before we said X I to zero
what was the value of X I and the
original assignment so yes why is it one
yeah so X I wasn't V - that's why so
it's 1 x xj was also in v - because that
that's the anomaly be sorry there was
not an edge in that week so this was
originally so this was 1 and this was 1
so this was 0 and this was 0 and 0 or 0
is this used to be 0 so what happens now
though let's change the changes to 1
right because X I goes to 0 now this
thing becomes 1 and such change to 1 so
there are be other classes with XII but
realize that not of X I is so if X is
chained is 0 not of X is changing to 1
so whatever happens here it'll only
increase the number of clauses that are
being satisfied so you lose only one but
you can but you gain at least one so
eventually it does not change
it does not change a number satisfied
clauses so that's important so what we
did is we started with some satisfying
assignments that we assumed existed and
then we just change a variable and we
said that it's still at least as many
clauses being satisfied so we did that
and now we have one less vertex that is
that is violating so we have now we have
one less vertex that is violating the
clique property so now we can now we can
take this step it's like setting X i20
we can just repeat this so how long do
we repeat this so we repeat this still
there are no longer any violations so
every time you find a violation so while
once we were to delete X I let this is
gone so now we look for the next
violation the next validation is this
edge so there's no edge there so we can
either take this vertex let's call this
K so you can either remove XK or remove
XJ we're on one of them and if you see Y
once you remove that equals we end up
you'll end up with the three quick so
what happens is once we repeat this
until V dash
so you could does that make sense well
you can do that we just keep deleting
vertices until this is a quick and that
those those classes last class
conditioner start satisfied you would
still have greater than equal to that
many clauses so now let's look at what
we have we have V dash which is a clique
and X I is equal to so when is X like so
once you have done this like process as
many times as you need when is X I equal
to one so remember that so V Dash is
also being updated every time you set X
i20 exercise me remove from V dash so
that property is always satisfied that
define V dash equal to i4 x I called one
that's property is always invariant that
means that even after doing all these
repeated repetitions you still have x
equals one if and only if and only if I
is even V Dash and zero otherwise so
does that make sense why that property
so holds so you have a clique and you
have this assignment so that should take
you back to this so remember where we
took a clique of size K and we found
that if you go through all the algebra
you will find something which is like
you will go through and you will get
modified ebar plus mod of V plus mod of
game right so here you have a clique so
forget about what you did before so I
just like consider like this is an
assignment according to those rules and
those rules give give you that you
should get number off satisfied clauses
is equal to mod of V bar plus mod of V
plus mod of V dash realize that V dash
here is not gay does that make sense
because V dash is just sorry started
with some set you started deleting some
elements you throw the Thrilla randomly
but you ended up with some V dash and by
this argument you had ebar plus mod of V
plus mod of V dash u bar from this class
we dash from me from this cause we die
from this class so you don't end up with
this
and you know that because of because of
what we showed here it does not change
the number of satisfied classes it's
still greater than equal to mod of V bar
plus mod of V plus okay and they cancel
this you cancel this and you get you get
mod of V dash is greater than equal to K
which means that which means that you
have a clique of size greater than equal
to K questions
does that make sense really open okay
that's good
any case so let's go back and see what
we were doing here so the way you're
doing it with NP reductions is np-hard
reductions is you take a problem that
you already know is hard you take any
random in any arbitrary instance an
instance of that problem and you
transform the input and into an input to
the problem that you're trying to show
is hard so you take problem a which you
know is hard the transform the input
into an input for problem B and then you
show that if you can solve the problem B
you'd be able to solve problem a but
since you know you can't trial problem a
in polynomial time you know that you
can't solve probably real time and the
and the other important thing to notice
here is that the reduction needs to be
polynomial time so let's look at this
reduction for instance what are you
doing here you're taking you're taking
every vertex you're making a clause and
how many clauses do you have well you
have about n square clauses here you
have all rent causes here and you've all
read causes here so time to construct
that is like roughly order N squared so
you're constructing the causes involved
in real time so you have a problem in
polynomial time reduction and if you
reduce a known np-hard problem in
polynomial time to an unknown problem
you can show that is np-hard
okay I don't think we have time to do
another problem so